it is practical to make money around the  thing that interests you the most it's  amazing  even though crush it is the furthest  thing from what I've done in this space  it's still the truest we live in an  Internet age where niches are long and  deep and you can make money doing  anything and the thing you'll make the  most money on is the thing you like the  most because it's the thing you like the  most will allow you the work the hardest  and that will be the variable of success  and if you love it so much  you'll also research it more because it  was what you'd naturally do anyway in  your free time and then you'll work  harder and then you'll make money not  you're a [ __ ] life coach